authorities have now identified the
driver who was going the wrong way on
the 15 last night before causing a fiery
crash that killed her and three other
people 37 year old erica morrell of
henderson was driving north in the
southbound lane on the 15 near gene when
that accident happened investigators say
impairment may have been a factor sally
jaramillo joining us now near the scene
of the crash with more what police are
saying is a frequent problem sally
yes denise many people still in shock
after hearing about yesterday's crash
they say wrong way driving is a serious
problem in the valley and it needs to
stop now
most important things to talk about is
the prevalence of impaired driving when
it comes to runway crashes andrew
bennett with the office of public safety
says in 2017 a hundred percent of wrong
way fatals involve impairment in 2019
that number was 90 percent we ended last
year
with 382 lives lost on nevada's roadways
and that's a 14-year high and it only
took two hours and 15 minutes for us to
have our first fatality and you know 11
days in sarah marks who has lived in the
valley for 30 years agrees i think it's
outrageous i've personally seen wrong
way drivers on the roads in las vegas
obviously this latest crash is horrific
justin hopkins with the nevada
department of transportation says they
are trying to help this serious problem
it uses a radar technology when a driver
is going the wrong way on the ramp
it sets off a system of flashing signs
that alerts that driver first it also
records video of that driver and it
sends it in real time out to all of our
law enforcement partners so in this test
over the course of three years they
found that wrong-way drivers were
alerted and turned around 89 percent of
the time before they got on the freeway
wake up
pay attention and if you're on the other
side of the road drive defensively
back out live hopkins adds they will
start the process of constructing those
on more off ramps across the state
starting this time by next year for now
reporting live near sloan salijaramillo
live local now